what's happening you bad [__]
oh [__]
it's gonna be a good week it's monday
the 13th of september the joint wants to
welcome
public wreck listen how many of you guys
like to chill out
relax you know a little ripped up torn
t-shirt
some nice sweatpants maybe some
flip-flops your feet are out you know
i'm saying you're showing people how
ugly your feet are
when you want to be comfortable and
stylish you got to get public wreck
you're like joey what's public rash
they're an athletic wear that meets
leisure it's a sweat pant that's
tailored to fit like a nice pair of
trousers in fact i got them on right now
let me tell you something i put them on
last tuesday because i have a test for
sweatpants i put them on for sleep first
and see how i feel around the house
and then i take them out for a day i
wore a pair to my daughter's practice
last week oh my god tremendous
and it's made for all sizes get the
best-selling all-day everyday pant
available in 40 different sizes and
it'll fit all kinds of guys
listen man
it's nice looking when you used to wear
them in high school you could wear these
anywhere the work happy hour the gym
barbecue the pants they saw me are
tremendous little zippers on the side
pockets in the back nothing could fall
out of your pants plus they make shorts
t-shirts jackets even golf gear you look
sharp while being comfortable listen i
love these sweatpants and you guys know
how much i love sweatpants public direct
rarely gives discounts but right now
they got an exclusive offer just for the
joint family go to publicrec.com right
now public wreck one word rec
and pressing joey to get 10 off the most
comfortable sweatpants
warm-up pants you'll ever wear shorts
t-shirts jackets tremendous that's
public wreck
p-u-b-l-i-c
iec
dot-com use promo code joey to get 10
off just do me a favor go to
publicrank.com and look at the sweats
that's all i want you to do i don't want
you to buy nothing just go look at them
see how the shiny they are how tight
they feel and like the man said
they look like trousers but they feel
like sweatpants they feel like
clouds on your nut sack and on your legs
you could sling dick in style and be
comfortable with public wrecked go to
publicrec.com right now
and preston joey to get 10 off you're
not gonna be sorry i love these warm-up
pants
the joint is also brought to you by from
the heart of [__] new jersey
draftkings week one may be over but the
season is just getting [__] started
get it on action with draftking
sportsbook app the official sports
betting partner of the nfl
for week two draftkings is giving new
customers
200 and free bets
instantly just bet one dollar
on any football game and you're in
did you [__] almost hear me
if you can't bet the sports book in your
state don't worry draftkings has huge
cash prizes up for grabs all season
along with their daily fantasy contest
download the draftkings fantasy
right now or draftking sportsbook app
use promo code joey to receive a deuce
and free bets when you place a dollar on
any football game whether it be college
pro i'm hooking you up this weekend
that's promo code joey to get you 203
bets but hold on one second i got a
little disclaimer for you to talk to you
about
draftkings the official sports betting
partner of the nfl you got to be 21 old
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only
new customers only and restrictions
apply you got gotta see draftkings.com
slash sportsbook for details now
if you got a gambling palm you gotta
call
1-800 gambler if you're in indiana it's
1 809 with it
if you got all the [__] everything
covered download the draftking
sportsbook app and let's win some
guitars we're not [__] around and the
action starts on thursday night
download the draftking sportsbook app
pressing code joey better dollar and get
203 bets go to draftkings right now the
joint is also brought to you by one of
my all-time favorites manscaped fall is
in the air
listen you can't be walking around with
that [__] afro between your [__]
legs and that skunk if you're an old man
like me you're [__] like a skunk
with all that hair around it
stop it right now trim that [__]
women are looking to suck dick and
you're still walking around with that
stinky [__] nut sack
bundle up with the manscape performance
package 4.0 they give you the new
lawnmower 4.0 i can give you a bunch of
marketing [__] [__] but listen it's
skin safe technology the bottom line is
it protects the [__] nut sack even my
long balls don't get caught in these
gears and the blades are sharp enough to
cut through white hairs like [__]
butter set the length of your trim from
one to four if you want to go old school
you could do that they even made the
light brighter they had a travel lock
and they made it [__] waterproof
so throw that in your weekend bag and be
set for any situation plus get the weed
whacker why is your nose look like a
[__] dick with hair coming out of it
trust me i got the same [__] problems
there's boogers i find in that [__]
nose afro that have been in there since
[__] that [__] and they're gonna throw
in the cop the crop preserver and the
crop reviver
all in the performance package who's
better than you
nobody and the performance package 4.0
is going [__] global getting in the
usa canada uk
europe australia south africa and
singers poor listen to me
you can't have a good looking dick if
you don't [__] shave it can you
imagine
if i didn't [__] shrimp my [__]
nut hair with the uncircumcised dick and
the scars and all that [__] you don't
need that make your dick look [__]
beautiful you ever go to a restaurant
the presentation
right they put like a slice of orange
and everything or it's the same thing
when you're showing that [__] [__] of
debt
it's the presentation so get 20 off from
free worldwide shipping when you go to
manscape.com joey again that's
manscape.com
joey no more stinky [__] ball has
[__] let's do this [__] right now
let's get the joint started it's [__]
monday
look where the beast stung me that
[__] let's do it
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 13th
of august we made it we didn't get
attacked
it was a great [__] weekend i'm
saying people were worried we were gonna
get attacked on saturday you know
everybody was walking around with a
[__] umbrella and [__] you know what
are you gonna do it was 20 years ago
we will [__] make it and never
[__] forget you understand me that's
all you could do it was a great week
last week
for starters [__] football is back
jack
[__] dallas covered on thursday night
you know me i'm a creepy [__] i took
tampa bay plus the 73 from draftkings
but i love the [__] dollars i don't
give a [__] free money is free money if
you guys didn't take it go [__]
yourselves you [__] up
but uh school was back my daughter's
very [__] happy we had a great week
last week we really [__] did monday i
don't know what happened
monday tuesday wednesday with great
[__] days around here with her
you know i had her i couldn't [__] do
a lot of [__] so i had to do some [__]
with her before school i mean
it was just great we took it to the gym
she jumped up and down
and then the weekend came we practiced
on friday night it was [__] fun
we were supposed to go to a football
game me and my wife looked at each other
were like [__] that we were supposed to
go to a practice well like it's [__]
freezing out here on friday night so
saturday we had a full [__] day of
games
she tied the first game and then she
lost two games for the all-stars direct
game she won
but the two games for the all-stars she
lost but it's
they got [__] 55 games i don't give a
[__] you know
and then uh what else did we do we came
home and this my friends were gonna have
a football game at 5 30
the fire department was going to be
there they were going to come up
firecrackers asbestos the whole [__]
thing
and we were like you know what man we've
been out of field all [__] day
we're just gonna sit home get some
chinese food
and [__] watch cruella and it was
tremendous i went
while the girls were showering i flew
over and got a little couple hot fudge
sundaes at [__] carvel you know what
i'm saying i came back we sat down like
a family and we watched cruella and i
got to tell you last week i watched the
disney movie what was disney slash
marvel and this week i watched a disney
movie and i gotta tell you something i
don't give a [__] how old you are those
disney movies are just great the [__]
music and cruella this week i mean i was
they played a song by joe tex you know
joe texas no you don't
trust me nobody [__] knows i know
because the song is
it's got to be
50 [__] years old
it's called i gotcha uh-huh huh it's
[__] jotex when i first came from
[__] cuban my mom had a bar in harlem
and i met that jasper williams the black
dude and on saturday nights that's why
african americans are so talented
because while you're out jumping up and
down watching football and all that
stupidity they're having talent contests
in the projects i swear to god we used
to have a talent contest
every [__] saturday night followed by
a soul trained [__] line of dancing
on saturday night that's what poor
people do that's why they're [__] so
advanced the [__] brothers with the
dancing and the [__] singing and the
talent when you look at usher you're
like what the [__] how did he get so
good he was singing when he was four
instead of you dumb [__] being
at disneyland see [__] being poor has
his benefits you know what i'm saying
you [__] are jumping up and
down at disneyland meanwhile the jackson
five is living in one room singing
that's all they could do they didn't
even have [__] food all they did
we hungry sing [__] sing
you're [__] hungry this is gary
indiana [__] you want to eat eat a
rat that's all there is to [__] eat
here but it's just interesting that you
watch these disney [__] movies
and they're entertaining i watch an
adult movie and i'm like
somebody [__] shoot me already you
know you watch an adult movie sometimes
it's like
they try so [__] hard to be so
[__] witty and you're like
this blows disney i don't even know half
the [__] actors like they don't even
like they had the rock and the one and
whatever and cruella but in [__] uh
the silver rings i didn't know nobody i
knew that one dude that was in the
sopranos the old man from sexy freak
that's the only dude
that's i don't even know if that's the
name of the [__] movie sexy animal
sexy beast
sexy beast that's the name of the
[__] movie that's the only guy i
recognized and he had a little part he
wasn't one of the stars of the [__]
movie when you have a movie you have to
have stars to draw it in disney don't
[__] do that they're great and then
they do [__] 90 million world [__]
wide then they hit you with by the ways
oh we we made [__] 200 million in
china we made 300 million in australia
you [__] get paid no wonder
[__] that chick sue when you the
black widow chick she got pissed off
she's like [__] she was just supposed
to [__] put in the movie theater you
weren't supposed to stream and then by
the way tell me oh by the way we made
[__] 90 mil in hong kong
really what are you [__] nuts or what
i want my end but now we watch cruella
and then football is back jimmy
florentine had his [__] uh weekly
little [__] bash i went over there
and said hello the first week was empty
you know just a couple of the savages
and then i went over to marlborough day
and that was it that was my [__] day
and that was the weekend
a tremendous [__] weekend no drama
i'm still getting hot and smoking the
daytime no edibles no nothing i'm
feeling better anxiety is minimal
minimal
i between the [__] i start you want me
to tell you something
i again i attribute it to the squats and
the deadlifts
people always say to me what are you
talking about
listen i don't give a [__] what's going
on with your life i'm an old [__] man
years ago i started squatting boom i
knocked up my wife
you squat
there's always positive [__] results
you squat first like i do my warm-up and
i put the heavy squats in i do my
warm-up on friday and i do the [__]
deadlifts wednesday is just a throwaway
day it's cables it's machines and some
free weights maybe some kettle weight
and kettlebells but mondays and fridays
i alternate the [__] squat and the
deadlift to build strength first you do
it because it tones the whole body not
just the legs and
it involuntary tones the [__] that's
very important when you're over 50 you
understand me you guys are young enjoy
it you can hit it with a [__] hammer
now light it on fire but once you're
over 50 you struggle with your [__]
you're like one of those indian dudes
with the [__] flute with the snake
it's a 50 50 chance you could be out
there all day blowing on that flute and
that snake don't come out or you could
just give it up
and the [__] thing pops up i got one
of those dicks right now but if i
deadlift and squat and do my protein
powders and i sleep
it's perfect the dick works a lot better
not that i'm giving out stabbings like
you know [__] china's giving out
coven i'm just [__] uh
i'm just [__] you know
you know whatever anyway it doesn't
really matter it's monday morning i just
want to talk to you guys from the heart
kate quigley is home she's feeling
better i spoke to her we kept it very
light you know how much i love her and
how much uh
i respect her she uh
you know
exactly what i said was gonna happen
listen people
died
and that's heavy
it's very heavy to open your eyes after
you've done a line of coke
and see three people on the floor or in
the chairs or whatever the [__] they
were
you know she's concerned about you know
the
tylenol whatever the [__] you call it
tethanol or whatever
fentanyl whatever the [__] it is
fentanyl tylenol it's all the [__]
same at the end of the week
um
you know but she's doing a lot better
you know
again right now she just needs to rest
um
she doesn't have to make a comeback
she said she's got a few weeks off
from comedy anyway so
it doesn't matter she's just gonna take
the time rest do some writing
she released the statement on twitter um
and that's it i'm uh
you know i'm gonna support her i got her
back
um
it was an accident you know it could
have happened to anybody you know it
could happen to me could happen to you
so before you judge i read a lot of the
things that people wrote
i didn't say anything you know a lot of
people sent positive stuff and
great stuff a few [__] uh maggots
sent garbage i didn't even reply to them
because they don't [__] matter in the
world
you know right now the world's in a
weird place
and you're going to be writing [__] like
that i can't even you know it's not even
worth addressing these [__] losers
but she's fine she's going to be all
right you know uh
the guy died on monday you know from
fentanyl god rest his soul the other act
the [__] guy was
a phenomenal act and it was crazy
because
he was he died monday and monday night
i did my stuff and when i after i played
the guitar i came in and my wife was
watching the sopranos and he was on that
episode of the sopranos we were like who
the [__] died today my wife's like him
i'm like yeah michael k so
uh you know it's just a bad [__] time
for that [__] and you know what's the
answer guys
i i read something and i spoke to a
friend of mine and what i read
and what my friend said well [__]
disturbing as [__]
to a guy like me and you guys know i'm a
junkie
you guys know i'm i'm not hiding
anything i'm a junkie
so he's like you know it's getting rough
out there with this [__] stuff it
seems like now i gotta buy a kit to test
my [__]
what
listen
there's no more testing
there's no testing
when you're doing blow and they're
putting
fentanyl and blow
and
you know
listen it's over
i'm telling you guys right now i'm an
old man i did it for 29 years
if i was in a room with two people and
two of them died
from fentanyl and i lived it's over and
even listen just
even being
an innocent bystander how i am now i'm
an innocent bystander i was in new
jersey when it went down the whole thing
you know some stuff went down in uh in
long island my heart goes out to their
families and whatnot
but the main [__] thing is that
even like if i was doing coke today i'd
have to [__] take a look and go
do i want to do a line of coke and
[__] die on the spot is it worth it
for a line of [__] coke and let me
tell you something yeah you're going to
test this is why i'm saying it's not
going to work out for you if you think
you're just going to get a testing kit
listen they have those things and
[__] edibles some edibles that's why
there's a lot of edibles i don't eat
unless i know the people
i don't eat their [__] edibles what
do you mean joey know the people i know
the company i know the people who make
the products i know the people
who come out and they stand behind the
product
and they you know it's like justin from
abx you know that guy came to all the
[__] shows on tuesday nights he would
talk you know i would i would not grill
him but i would ask him questions about
how they would make those abx capsules
and what makes them
stronger and
not one time they say [__] fentanyl i
doubt he would say [__] fentanyl
anyway
but you know you just got to be [__]
careful
you know sometimes you eat something you
feel a little different a little weird
right there you know what i'm never
gonna eat those things again i don't
know if they have fun and all that and i
don't have time to take him to the lab
one of my scientists
would have a [__] beaker with [__]
suits and lights and [__] i don't have
that but i'm not going to get no [__]
tester he was telling me that he had a
friend of his he talked to a friend of
his
that they're doing a festival for them
to have a room to test their drugs are
you [__] crazy
once it's time to test street drugs it's
time to give it a breather
or just do whatever the [__] work around
it
i would never do a line of coke again
after the cake wiggly thing just out of
respect for rico fool and natalie the
three the three people who died i would
never do a line of coke again that's why
i would base that promise off of
to those three
you know what that's like to think
you're gonna have a good time that's
like going on a roller coaster that
thing flies off the [__] tracks it's
the same [__] thing with fentanyl you
were trying to have a good time it's not
listen it's not [__] legal
whatever and this is an argument for a
lot of people why they should make drugs
legal again
when it comes to heroin and coke and i
don't want to make those [__] things
legal i just don't not right now
not right now the world isn't too much
turmoil to start making those drugs
[__] legal what you have to do is
just avoid them that's it that's that
that's what i would [__] do
that's my [__] story and i'm sticking
to it and i got no reason to lie that's
it i would [__] just quit
you know when i was in l.a i knew for a
fact like i told you guys last week
all those pills that these people go
down to mexico and buy and they think
they're being cute there's fentanyl in
them
who knows who makes these [__] things
do i trust the mexicans to have a
pharmacist it could be anybody it could
be a narco what if he turns around and
one extra drop goes into the [__]
pill you don't know these things
remember i grew up with the [__]
quaalude things
i grew up in quaaludes were [__] uh
you know uh prominent they were they
were they were ecstasy they were [__]
everything rolled up into one
quaaludes and one day [__]
they banned them and also and people
started making
[__] quaaludes at home and i've got
to tell you something man there was a
lot of car accidents a lot of trees got
bumped into
a lot of people broke their necks on
bicycles because like i said the track
the table was crooked
you know they would make these quail
loots and the table would be [__]
unbalanced so
all the strength from the [__] pills
would go down the [__] table and
they'd be in these last 20 pills
these 80 pills up here
were mediocre [__] strength
so the guy would tell you the quaaludes
are great you would eat a mediocre pill
and go nothing's really happening and
then eat a three dosa
and [__] them pass the [__] out next
thing you know you're getting [__] in
the ass by cosby you don't know what the
[__] going on that's why because you
did a three [__] dosa instead of a
regular doser so this dose here they had
enough of a dose but the real strong
stuff went into these 20 pills down here
so when you ate one of these 20 pills
you lost it and trust me man
there was a couple nights i don't have
to [__] lie to anybody i didn't know
dee
but my eyes were in the back of my
[__] head and that's not a good
[__] feeling when somebody tells you
next day dog i went to wake you up and
the eyes were in the back of your
[__] head that's not a great [__]
feeling and eventually one day i stopped
[__] eating them and i got to be
honest with you when i was in aspen
colorado i was buying them up there
across the street from the internet
house
and one night i bought a bad batch of
those quaaludes and i think that's what
made me stop [__] eating them i
remember one night i had to go to the
[__]
i think i told this on stage for a while
i was telling this [__] joke on stage
for a while it's not really a joke it's
a story
i was living with my friend jimmy burkel
god rest his soul
and it was my first halloween in aspen
and i don't know if you guys know about
aspen they have a [__] fantastic
halloween it's a tremendous [__] more
crawl
people get dressed up they come from all
over colorado
they drive up to aspen and they walk
down [__] uh
the popular street in aspen i don't know
if it's galena i [__] forget now
but you know we got all excited i was
[__] 19 years old maybe 18.
jimmy was maybe 23 we were kids
and we're like we're going to [__]
aspen tonight we're gonna [__] get
dressed up so we we made the decision
the sunday
halloween was on halloween fell on a
weekend no not that [__] week
halloween fell on a monday night
and we had decided on sunday we were
talking [__] outside we on sundays and
in snowmass and 83 we would play [__]
uh flag football
down by the golf course and then after
that we would [__] cook
these guys from new orleans would
[__] cook tremendous [__] and then we
would go back to their house and watch
football it was a [__] party so they
were talking about it one day like we're
going to go up to the mall crawl and
meet jimmy berkel and my friend cato
were like yeah let's [__] go we'll
have a bang up [__] time the whole
thing the next day i went to work at
aspen electric i get home
cato shows up with these [__]
tremendous quaaludes from woody creek
you could tell they were [__] fugazis
because the aurora
that's how you could tell because they
were either aurora or lemon
and you could see that the guy who
actually sketched it [__] and had
like a shaky hand like he didn't have
his shot of vodka that thing so the
[__] hell on the lemon would be a
little [__] up and [__] you know
please listen you didn't give a [__] you
didn't give a [__] a quail was a
quaalude so he shows up with three of
those [__] bootleg quaaludes we
[__] ate them and we said listen
let's watch the football game because in
colorado the football game comes on at
seven we go what are we gonna go out at
seven let's watch the football game at
seven and then like 9 30 we'll head up
to aspen it's only a half hour right
it'll take us five minutes to get
[__] parked and we can walk around
jesus christ
all three of us ate those gorilla
biscuits
next thing you know we wake up it's
midnight [__]
we just went down no alcohol no nothing
just a gorilla biscuit and next thing
you know i woke up at midnight jimmy
burko was snoring cato was on the
[__] floor face [__] down drooling
like [__] what's his name from narcos
when they woke him up when they raided
the pot [__] field and they woke him
up and he had foam coming out of his
mouth tremendous i woke up with foam on
my face many a [__] time that's when
you know you had a good [__] night so
uh
those are the [__] bootleg quaaludes
and i'm like thank god
i didn't eat this quaalude and go out
because i would have just passed out
i would have just passed the [__] out of
the barn
again somebody could rape you
stick a finger up your ass you don't
need that aggravation on the quaalude
they used to be people who used to go
out just looking for quaalude victims
people that were [__] holding the
wall or dropping glasses but who gives a
frenchman's [__]
anyway
what i wanted to talk about this week
was something very important that
i've learned the last year
i learned about it the last year and it
was
i learned it the hard way and i learned
it
the [__] software
it was uh
really weird and today we're going to
talk about laughter
how important laughter is you know
i love north bergen new jersey i i
always loved it i
i thanked it for my sense of humor
i thanked it for my balls
and i thank north bergen
for
what they did for me after my mother
died
i was always very grateful
to north bergen for the three things
they did for me
when i came back
to when i moved back to jersey i thought
i would be involved
more in north bergen
and i went up there and it's really
rough to drive around it's a lot of
traffic you know
but i realized that my friends were gone
and i have friends up there i have great
friends
but the dudes i had come up with the
dudes that made my [__] day
were roger
stinky
ferny
mike ronnie you know mike ronnie's in
delaware
roger's dead god rest his soul
stinky
he's
working and he is
you know his life's changed
and my other buddy ferns is half
[__] you know he just uh
the gambling and the drugs early on just
[__] them up and i don't have those
friends anymore
there some of them are alive but we're
just uh different people now you know
and
and that's been the case with a lot of
my friends with different people and
i can understand that but i'm always
very grateful to them
because they taught me the gift of
laughter and
and when i you know a lot of people go
to me dog you had a rough [__]
childhood you know how the [__] did you
listen if you knew how much i left
you know and i got to throw steve avillo
in there i got to throw a lot of guys in
there
my mind was taken over by laughter i
laughed so much and yeah at night when
the party was over i would cry myself to
sleep because my mother wasn't around
and i was sad and i was living with
somebody and my life wasn't what i
wanted it to be
but laughter surrounded my life a lot
you know
and i'm not talking about like stand-up
comedy or watching movies that's a big
[__] difference it's not like i
turned down a movie and it [__] made
my day i i enjoyed movies i enjoyed
going to the movies
but just having people that were funny
around me
really changed my [__] outlook on
things like i really
[__] helped me so i've always as a as
a human being have turned to laughter
you know
the last year
you guys mentioned it to me
i mentioned that to you there wasn't a
lot of laughter in my life you know like
i just didn't uh have anything to laugh
at i couldn't focus on laughing lately
i've been [__] howling again by
myself and that's always a good sign i
have to laugh by myself you know nobody
can make me [__] laugh i have to
giggle at a light like i'm at a light
and i think about ralphie may falling
down on burke rice's dollhouse and i
then i [__] laugh i the other dad was
laughing about a friend of mine who
threatened me once with a toothpick in
his mouth
and while he was threatening me he did
something a toothpick went into his
throat and he almost choked you know
[__] like that that that's my sense of
humor you know
when uh the other day i went to the gym
and anthony the owner of the gym has a
little office and he was sitting with
the guy that referred me to the dentist
i went in there on purpose and i blew a
tremendous fart there's no windows in
there or nothing the guy told me the
next day that his contact
lens is melted how bad the farts are i
go in there sometimes i blow tremendous
farts you know when you bend over you
have to slam the ball and [__] you have
farts that are caught on your ribs and
stuff that are a few days old that you
have to put into the [__]
into the [__] turnpike to get the
party started so i mean you know i love
all that [__] but
my point is this you know
i go i've been my daughter's been
playing softball now for whatever since
march whatever the [__] six months
i don't know seven months
we didn't play in la
she started playing [__] here i'm
happy that she plays it
is she [__] don clinden no is she
[__] uh the player from the
the angels the the the japanese guy
ohtani no you know
she's just a little girl that's learning
how to [__] play and i enjoy it i
enjoy going to watch her i enjoy seeing
her drop the ball i've enjoyed watching
this journey you know
but at the practices
and at the [__] games
there's always a parent
that
you could tell he's pistol pete's
[__] father and he drives me [__]
crazy that [__] drives me crazy
you know
you want to push a girl or a child away
from you
you force him into doing something
listen
with my daughter it's whatever the [__]
she wants to do i always look at and go
listen if you want to do it the day you
don't want to do it you don't have to do
it you know i take it a kickboxing now
but there's one day a week they break
out those [__] sticks
those tie sticks i love it i i i'm happy
that they're teaching that if anybody
who knows martial arts like hawaiian
martial arts when they teach you
hawaiian martial arts first they teach
you with the sticks
then it's the knife the shorter your
distance and then it's hand to hand so
it's the whole [__] deal the whole
package you learn different ranges
so i understand but i always ask after
she does that particular class and we
don't want to come to this class no more
you don't have to she goes no i like it
you know that's my point my point is
that [__]
i don't want to force her into doing
something she doesn't want to do
because 20 years from now she's going to
hate me for it i don't want that you
don't want to do it don't do it
you don't see me doing nothing i don't
want to [__] do
i hate doing stuff that i don't want to
[__] do
you know
so
why would i [__] do it the first time
she tells me she doesn't want to go to
kickboxing i throw the [__] boxing
gloves away that's it are you sure do
you want me to save the boxing gloves to
hit the bag in the garage is there
anything no okay fine the first time she
tells me she doesn't want to play
softball boom we get rid of the [__]
bats we give the equipment to somebody
i'm not i'm not the type of guy because
i understand how it backfires i'm the
type of [__] i won't do whatever
the [__] i don't want to do i don't give
a [__] whose feelings get hurt or who
gets pissed off it's your life
you can't be living your life for
somebody to [__] else so they could jump
up and down i don't have time for that
[__] you do that [__] when you're a kid
once you have an adult and you have your
own family you have to [__] your time
has to be a little bit and that's what
was
those are the things i took care of when
i came from l.a
taking care of my time
my time was spread out for people i had
to cancel that
i had to cancel that [__] venue that
venue was canceled that that you know i
was spending three hours a day going
back
with people that had no interest in what
i was doing they just
wanted to take up my time and one day
when i went back to him and said i'm not
doing this anymore you could hit me all
you want on [__] twitter and facebook
but don't call me i don't have time
to take away from my daughter when i'm
gonna call my daughter to talk to you
about whatever things you have in your
life i had to really look at my [__]
time and adjust my [__] time to me
you know to make it work for me a lot of
people had a problem with that i'm
[__] sorry i cannot help you i have
an eight-year-old i have a wife and i
have responsibilities and i'm a [__]
58 year old man i don't do what i used
to do anymore you know i wish i'd go eat
eight slices of [__] pizza i can't do
that no more so i [__] don't you know
so my point is that
every [__] week during baseball
i gotta sit at a [__] practice
with two or three parents that during
the game
they get mad they're [__] saying [__]
about the coaches
they're saying [__] about [__]
the other why do they keep swinging at
the stuff that they're not supposed to
swing at
douchebag did you ever think about that
they're eight [__] years old
they're eight and nine years old
do you think that this [__] matters
on their life what they're doing right
now when they're eight or nine years old
you know my daughter tied the first game
and then
and
she did good the first game it was a
wreck game so she had a few hits and
[__] she got him i think she did uh
she was three for four she batted three
for four during the first game that's
great but the all-star games she's
playing up
she's eight and she's playing with 10
and 11 year olds
so she's not doing too good but i don't
i don't really give a [__] she played as
a catcher yesterday for three innings
and she did sensational
she knew where everything was she threw
somebody out at home she recovered a
bunk and stepped on home plate she threw
somebody out of third and she drew a
couple people out at first
very good [__] job you know but for
me i i want her to do it to have fun
she was out there for [__] six hours
playing with her little girlfriends
yelling
singing we are the whatever mayhem
they stomp they [__] eat candy they
[__] throw [__] you know that i don't
give a [__] if she strikes out off for a
[__] times i don't give a [__] if she
misses the ball at all [__] times
gets hit there
all i want from her
is to laugh
that's it and you can hear them
giggling and i mean i'm 100 yards away
from her in that dugout i don't sit
behind the dugout i stay on the other
side i want to get a little vitamin d
we have a lot of [__] room there
there's a little awning you could sit
under you don't have to get sun so yeah
we were there for six hours yesterday
but three hours i was in the sun as you
could tell by the color
i still got it you know what i'm saying
you could tell by the color
that [__] uh you know i i did three
hours in the sun and three under the
awning but that's not the point
the point here is that
she's [__] laughing
and those other girls on the field
are [__] laughing but this parent is
like
the pitching isn't isn't consistent
it's the [__] first day
it's the first game
and then my wife gets into the
conversation well
and i had to say something like
timeout you know what what is this espn
i haven't i didn't see you or you on the
1986 [__] mets
so until i see you in the 1986 mets
or the 2000 whatever boston red sox won
the championship or the [__] yankees
i advise that you shut your [__]
mouth
i hate these [__] people that you
know what the [__] do you do with your
[__] life and you're sitting there
bad-mouthing [__] four guys that
coaching little girls probably for free
because their daughters are on the team
sitting out there in the [__] heat
for six [__] hours on a [__] well
they give those guys 40 bucks for the
[__] day they're not doing it for the
40 bucks they do it because they enjoy
it they enjoy being around our daughters
they enjoy [__] the camaraderie and
they want to make sure that daughter
gets raised right whatever me do i play
softball no did i ever play softball
organized i did a couple [__] things
but i don't know about softball so
you're not going to see my [__] cuban
ass giving out orders or telling people
how to work out or i don't know about
that [__] that's not my world i go there
say how you doing coach what's happening
i'm respectful to the [__] coaches i
sit down i bring my little bottle of
water my little nicotine gums
and i [__] mind my business i chew
gum and i [__]
drink my [__] water i don't say
anything
every couple innings i get up i walk
around i go by mercy i check up on her
you know how you doing what's going on
the [__] dugout they're like mercy is
that your dad he looks like grandpa from
the monsters like yeah that's me [__]
sucking grandpa from the monsters and i
walk back i don't i don't go up down i
remember the rules i don't there ain't
no [__] rules
the rules are have fun
that's the [__] rule have fun run
around the bases slide get bit by a
mosquito look at this i got bit by a
[__] bee yesterday yeah i don't give
a [__] i was sitting there i looked down
the bee was doing his job i just flung
him he [__] he [__] flung back he
landed and i lit him on fire i must have
killed
six flies at that [__] baseball game
yesterday by myself they would land on
my leg i'd hit him and i didn't i was i
was throwing him in the grass at first
but then when i was in the [__] uh
when i was sitting in the awning it's
concrete
so i was killing the flies and throwing
them on the concrete and then i would
take a little wing off
and put them there and i would throw a
little water on them you know what i'm
saying so they could stay [__] a
little dehydrated or hydrated i don't
want my flies to be rehydrated i made
sure they got a suntan and before i left
i stepped on them and that was the end
of the [__] flies four [__] flies
could put
i had three other ones on the other side
that i [__] killed
and they were [__] kaput
my point is man you gotta [__] just
laugh
that's it and that's what i wasn't doing
my first year
i was having a hard time laughing i
forgot i'm the move was overwhelming
you know i was concerned with covid the
[__] numbers
the whole [__] deal and you know now
i just don't give a [__] i'm not putting
myself in cold video situations
you know i'm not getting on any [__]
planes
i'm just trying to live my life to the
best of my [__] ability
i got therapy tomorrow
i got notes for the [__] therapist
you know i go in there
a hundred percent now i'm trying to
address whatever issues i may have
that i have on the fence you know
something that's bothering me whatever
and i gotta be honest with you man
six months ago i didn't think i would
[__] make it till [__] september
it was just a struggle i was having a
hard time from day to day
but a lot of things happened
that helped me [__] change one of
them i'll tell you man
was the therapy uh
two
was the journaling
and three
was that new [__] alpha brain that
new black
[__] box edition of the alpha brain
that [__] is a [__] sizzler
and if you look at me
six months ago and what i was talking
about behind this microphone
and if you judge me by what i'm talking
about today
if i was you i get some of that [__]
if you're feeling how i did you know i
had some mental health issues and the
anxiety but i couldn't focus
you know it wasn't like i was depressed
i'm never really depressed but i kind of
was i didn't know what i wanted to do i
was feeling ho-hum as they say is that
what you call it i'm feeling a little
ho-hum
and uh
i changed
you know the workout a little bit to
make a little bit more strength
so my body could utilize protein a
little better you know so i wanted to do
that
you know guys i work hard on what i'm
trying to [__] accomplish here i'm
one of these guys that
i'm kind of happy like i'm getting
emails from people now like the word no
is a powerful word and
[Music]
people can't comprehend it sometimes it
took me years to comprehend the word no
and once i started using it more it's
i understood the word no
from the [__] perspective you know
because i'm a [__] [__] as a comic
and it's weird now
i feel as if
i feel like i have that aspect
under control
um
the journaling helped me a lot to read
back the notes
of what i was feeling to [__] attack
you know i didn't want to feel the way i
was feeling anymore i wasn't doing a
couple weeks ago i did the patreon
podcast
and i think that was the uh
that was the peak of it i i was just
not depressed but i wasn't feeling it
i'm the type of guy that if i don't feel
i'm doing you a justice i don't want to
do it anymore why are we wasting our
[__] time i don't want to waste your
time i don't want to waste my [__]
time
and it's so weird that that's been the
that has been
my formula last year that it's just as
i'm about to give up
boom i see [__] daylight you know it
started with the knee
the knee surgery was brutal there was
one weekend where the pain i was taking
a pill i swear to you guys
i was taking a pill and it wasn't doing
anything
my shin was on [__] fire
and i remember that there was a point
where i had a two [__] pain pills and
i remember that two or three hours later
the pain started coming up again i
remember i actually called
the doctor's office on a [__] sunday
and made it like an emergency call you
know like when they're like if it's an
emergency the answering service and
actually the doctor called me back
that was the one time he was good and i
was like dog this pain
is [__] horrible i cannot take
anymore and he's like i don't know what
to tell you
i said you know what [__] you and i went
i called a friend of mine
and i said do you have anything stronger
for [__] pain
i know he had fallen out of a [__]
helicopter or something 20 years ago i
know what the [__] happened to this guy
he landed on his head
so he said i got one of those extra
strength [__] i forget what the [__]
you call them
i said i'll take it i took that [__]
pill
and yeah it neutralized the pain
but it made me feel even shittier you
know like i don't do well on pain pills
i was like this has to end and the next
day i woke up and the pain had dropped
[__]
50 i never established that pain
so it got worse before it got better as
you could tell this week i'm having a
good week
the last
three episodes i've been flowing a
little more
sunday two weeks ago i had a little
[__] breakdown i was at a party
and i was just sitting with talking to
people the way i'm talking to you
[__] right now
and you know just sitting there all
something like wait a second my stomach
don't feel right and also i was like
oof i think i'm gonna pass out holy [__]
i think i'm gonna fart and all of a
sudden i started closing my eyes
i think i'm gonna [__] pass out i
think i'm gonna pass out and i go i
can't pass out here i'm in [__] the
neighbor's house they're gonna [__]
never invite me over again
i go i gotta reach for my i gotta figure
out a way to get my wife
and before i could go for my wife i
looked up and she was right there
and i clung on to her and she walked me
in and i could i didn't pass out or
anything i sat down
but i felt so [__] shitty that day
like my arm was sweating from here to
here it was just sweating even my wife
said i've never seen something like that
your arm just sweating like that i've
never seen nobody [__] do it
that was the worst i ever felt
i came home sunday night i didn't feel
too [__] good i even told my wife
that i'm a little concerned i might go
to the doctor tomorrow
the way i'm feeling my body feels cut
boom
i woke up [__] monday morning feeling
tip top [__] magoo and i felt better
the whole [__] week so
it gets worse before it gets better
that's what i realized with me this year
that
i have like a bad bad bad [__] day
and the next day it eases up a little
bit so
laughter is the whole [__] thing man
and uh for a long time i don't know what
was going on i wasn't laughing enough
i wasn't hanging out with the wrong
right people like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
since when
yeah you know when i was a kid and i was
hanging out with fernie and roger they
were funny [__] people
but i gotta be honest with you guys i've
always found the laughter
as funny as crazy as it sounds
i've always found the laughter from
within
you know it's it's when i'm sitting
there and i just burst out into [__]
tears you know when i think about
ralphie
when i think about lee puking that night
on the mushrooms
where he just puked on his shirt and
looked at me and he goes are we at the
hospital and i'm like no we're not at
the hospital he kept asking oh yeah
every every 15 minutes we would talk and
he would go
you're not going to take me to the
hospital are you and i'm like nah i'm
going to take you to the hospital you
know i was thinking about the night that
like i have tons of material in my head
to laugh at guys
i was thinking about the other night i
said well i wasn't thinking about it i
was reminded of it
the other night i was practicing the
guitar and then i went on youtube
to watch eric clapton uh play uh
eyesight to the blind with santana
eyesight to the blind there's no song he
did from tommy with the who
[__] eric clapton shreds that [__]
guitar
but i heard it on the radio with santana
i was sitting there and i'm like oh my
god eyesight to the blind very [__]
cool
but also i'm like wow it must be live
because he sounds like santana
and then i looked at the radio was on
sirius you know they're the only ones
that play that type of music i looked at
the radio and said santana and [__]
eric clapton i'm like holy [__] i was
right so when i came home that night i
put on [__] in the video to see it
[__] tremendous
but while i was looking for the video
i saw the the paulie tunes video
of the night that i gave i i'll never
forget i forgot it till i saw it
but once i saw the video i [__] was
dying to laugh the guys
it was
one day somebody gave me a 500 milligram
brownie oh it was in san jose
the dudes up there the [__] uh
the dudes that sold the gummy bears
[__]
had a 500 milligram brownie and i
remember i ate a whole one at the san
jose improv and i had to run and get a
piece of chicken because i thought i was
going to pass out because it [__]
shot up it was terrible it just shot up
my anxiety and i had like 10 minutes
before i got on stage and i'm like holy
[__] i'm gonna pass out so i just ran in
the kitchen and told the guy let me get
a [__] chicken sandwich i'm one of
those dead chicken sandwiches those
chickens that haven't been kicked you
know which ones i'm talking about the
grilled ones not the fried ones that are
kind of [__] good the grilled ones
that they actually put like the magic
marker to show you it's been on a grill
but that thing hasn't been on a [__]
grill like burger king yeah
so
i'll never forget i brought the brownies
home
and one afternoon i saw lee
we done like a one o'clock podcast or
something and we split the [__]
brownie it was a 500 milligram brownie
we split it and we took like a death
star
like who would do something like this
and the next thing you know he goes
[__] home
and uh
oh [__] that was quick
he goes [__] home and
i am [__] high as a kite i am as high
as a georgia pine
and i am sitting there and i'm like what
the [__] is going on with me
so i'm a little lonely whatever and i
just picked up the phone
and i started telling lee
if the cops call
you don't know nothing and i would just
hang up
and then my phone would ring and i
wouldn't answer it it would be lee
calling me back
and i wouldn't answer and then he would
leave a message what do you mean at the
cops call and i would wait an hour every
hour on the hour
i would call him at the top of the aisle
and go leak
if the cops call don't answer the phone
and hang up on him and sure enough he
would call right back why are the cops
gonna call
tell me tell me
i'm looking out the window i can't take
it anymore
i did that to him all [__] night till
about one in the morning
i kept calling him don't [__] and if
the cops call
don't answer the [__] phone
and finally he's like why not why can't
i answer the [__] phone and i'm like
lee
because i [__] said so
that's why all right don't answer the
[__] phone the cops are gonna call
[__] and they kept saying am i
gonna go to jail and i'm like no you're
not gonna go to jail they just wanna ask
you a couple questions about sex and
rape and he's like what's going on huh
the next day i call them i'm like lee
what the [__] is your problem
i'm just goofing on you you don't know
that after all these [__] years and
i'm just torturing you that
don't answer the phone cause the cops
you [__]
it never [__] ends like i said man i
have
stories in my head that i laugh at
all day when we're writing this [__]
book
you know there's always a story a
serious story in every chapter but
there's always a story that goes along
with that story
that happened that's just as [__]
funny as any [__] story i mean and we
discussed it the other day we're like
every [__] chapter
has like a serious story like my mother
dying or something but then it goes into
something else that you're like what the
[__] is he talking about
so
i love all this [__] i love listen man
just because i'm not doing stand-up
doesn't mean i'm not funny anymore i
still [__] got it like a [__]
i was just having some problems
it was hard for me to communicate
it was really hard for me to [__]
communicate i was having a rough [__]
time of it and
uh you know getting adjusted to the new
medication was rough
there was just a lot of things you know
the move the house
there were so many things i overlooked
before i moved
i thought i had this but i didn't have
this
you know and i'm not ashamed to say i
didn't have this you know we have these
things that you're on top of and you
have
there's things that you don't have and
this move
everything that went over with this move
i didn't really have it i didn't control
it
and now i'm in control now i feel a lot
better
i'm still in the 270 [__] mark you
know i can't bust a 270 but i don't give
a [__] i'm not looking to go to the
olympics i'm not looking to fight in the
ufc i'm not looking to do any of that
[__] i'm just looking to be [__]
healthy right now
happy to keep doing the podcast
keep your heads together and keep you
[__] happy that's all i'm
looking to [__] do right now nothing
else and it bothers me a little bit like
i'm still like
oh every [__] week i'm say i say to
myself i'm gonna do stand-up next week
every week i say it to myself i'm gonna
do stand-up next week i'm gonna do
stand-up next week i still haven't
[__] done it and i don't miss it
or anything one good thing i have done
and i feel a lot better since i went
back is acupuncture i went back to
[__] acupuncture it feels great man
some of the needles in my ear hurt
the first week you know she even told me
you're bleeding because i take the baby
aspen i mean all i do is cut myself and
[__] it's a gasher of [__] blood
within the within the blood thinners and
the [__] baby aspirin
every time i go to the dentist the
dentist calls me don't take your
medication thing i don't want you
bleeding all over this [__] i'm
over yeah the blood that comes out of me
is [__] ridiculous so
but that's it and that's that man i
wanted to touch base with you guys on a
beautiful monday morning i know uh
the weekend was rough you know
911 was very [__] rough for a lot of
people
like i told you guys last week my
neighbor was involved in 911
and they interviewed him for the
documentary on uh
on discovery he was on in three episodes
and
i watched two of them and they were very
[__] disturbing you know
it's very disturbing for anybody i think
about walking down there
you know one thing about me that people
forget is yeah i'm a big jersey guy but
i used to be a big new york city guy i
went to grammar school in new york city
i grew up in new york city i was around
times square constantly i got beat at
three card monte i mean i did everything
in that [__] city
so i [__] knew it so when it went
down
it kind of was a weird feeling because
it kind of bothered me because i
couldn't help
you couldn't help i was 2 000 miles away
i couldn't help nobody get into a train
i couldn't help nobody get off the train
you couldn't help you know and now i'm
here
and uh
it was a weird day you know i'm happy i
had the baseball games
and other other things going on i was
going to go to the 911.
they had a little thing at the wreck
yesterday for 9 11 when i got caught up
with the games
i was gonna go and at least uh
my neighbor's name is frank puma a great
[__] guy
you know uh i was at least go over there
and say hello but i say hello to them
every day over here what do i gotta go
to the park and say hello for i could
just cross the street and say hello to
this [__] over here
but i know it was a lot it was rough for
a lot of i used this weekend
especially a lot of east coast people
you know my heart goes out there i went
through the same thing but hey it was 20
years ago we're a better america now
regardless of what's going on with
vaccines and mandates
you know and uh
we're on the upswing man i [__] feel
it numbers are going down a little bit
you know hopefully uh
by the end you know i was really
heartbroken
because i thought the numbers were going
to go up like the way they did in
florida and california and then we're
going to shut the movies and stuff like
this i really wanted to see this
premiere
and i really wanted to uh on patreon
i'm trying to get a movie theater to
take some of the people from patreon
on uh when the sopranos movie comes out
to many saints
and it looks like it's going to happen i
mean it's the [__]
13th of the month unless something uh
weird happens in the next 10 or 15
[__] days
which i don't know about you know
it looks like it's going to happen so
i'm excited that the many saints
is going to have a premiere and uh
everything is looking up guys so thank
you very much
for supporting and thank you
for having my back to last year i know
it's been rough especially after eight
years of the church and sticking fingers
and [__] and
eating stars of death and people passing
out but
listen we had to make an adjustment
i had to adjust to a new [__]
circumstance and uh i'm really proud
that i was able to step up it took a
while
but i'm really proud i was able to step
up and [__] handle my business and
[__] the most important thing is
football is back
uh it was great yesterday and uh
that's it
you know hopefully the numbers will go
down and we'll have a decent [__]
fall
and my daughters our children will be
able to stay in school
without [__] uh zooms and [__] like
this
and that's it and that's that i love you
[__] i'm happy we got to start
the week off on a good foot and we'll be
back [__] wednesday
with a guest this time a little
interview for you [__]
and that's it and that's that it's
monday i want to keep it short i don't
want to take too much of your time i
know you [__] have other things
on your plate but it's a beautiful
[__] day to be alive go out there and
[__] tackle it you know what i'm
saying
uh don't take life for granted look at
kate she'll tell you
don't take life for granted the biggest
the biggest [__] gains i did in my
life
they were the hardest things it was when
my mother died
and when i went to prison but my
mother's debt taught me not to take my
friends or my family or people around me
for granted and during that time in
prison taught me not to take my life for
granted that you don't want to be behind
bars our parents [__] for hours for us
to be [__] born and for us to do
something good and i'm positive
it's not sitting in a [__] jail i'd
rather you sit at home and look at the
computer than sit at [__] jail it's
not jail so once i went to prison i got
the opportunity to never [__] take
life for granted never take my freedom
for granted i never drank drunk and
drive because you ever [__] try
walking to the [__] movie theater it
sucks you losing your [__] driving
privileges so all these things don't
take anything for granted
if there's one thing you learned from
kate last week is don't take life for
granted
save every [__] moment you don't know
when you're gonna be hanging out with
three of your buddies
smoke a joint and one of them [__]
dies you know what i'm saying you never
[__] know anymore life is a
[__] so enjoy it it's monday the
13th of [__] september i love you
[__] with all my heart attack
this [__] day don't take life
for granted and at the end of the day
they all suck your dick anyway
i love you [__] i'll see you next
wednesday
tiptop magoo
ready to go and now for a [__]
word from our sponsor jack all right you
bad [__] i want to thank you
again
for the monday morning podcast
we covered a couple things laughing
happiness football
nose hairs i don't [__] know anyway
the joint is brought to you by let me
tell you something from the heart of
[__] new jersey draftkings
listen the first week of football is
over but the season is just getting
started we all know this [__] it's time
to make some [__] money
download the draftking sportsbook app
the official sports betting partner of
the nfl and let's get this [__] party
started the holidays are coming
thanksgiving's coming you want to have
some money in your pocket you don't want
to be [__] broke like a [__] joke
so what we're doing is this at
draftkings we're giving away new
customers
200 and free bets just better dial on
the nfl game use code joey and i'm going
to [__] take care of you with 2000
credits draftkings is safe secure and
reliable you could draw your money when
the [__] you want it's your money plus
the lines are great the casino is great
you could play blackjack you could play
[__] roulette you could play poker
it's happening all at draftkings and
you're sitting there like a [__] momo
i took the [__] the thing this week
tampa bay plus the 73 you know i'm a
[__] betty the mooch i won myself a
little 40 dollars i don't give a [__]
say what you want to say
download the draftking sportsbook app
today use promo code joey
bet a dollar and
dollars receive
free bets [__] instantly who's better
than you
nobody you understand me i'm gonna give
you 200 [__] bucks and free bets and
all you got to do is one thing
download the draftking sports baguette
if they don't have uh gambling in your
state download the draftkings
fantasy app they're giving a million
dollars away over there and you're
sitting there like a [__] [__]
going oh
kansas city is gonna win today put your
money where your mouth is [__]
download the draftking sportsbook app
the official sports betting partner of
the nfl now i got some [__] little
couple things i got to tell you you got
to be 21 over
you got to be in new jersey indiana
pennsylvania colorado those states new
customers only and restrictions do apply
you got to see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming pum
call 1-800 gambler if you're in indiana
call 1-800-9 with it but if everything's
okay download the draftking sportsbook
app and let's win some [__] money
whether it's the fantasy app or the
sportsbook app uncle joey's coming
through for you the joint would want to
welcome public wreck you know i love my
[__] sweatpants you know i love my
balls to be free
and if you want to be comfortable and
stylish you got to get some public wreck
i'm telling you these [__] sweatpants
are tremendous this is where athletic
meets [__] leisure they're tight they
feel like [__] beautiful trousers
they're light
they got little zippers so you won't
[__] do them with my other sweats
when i go to the gym i put my phone in
the pocket and if i'm on the bicycle the
[__] phone falls out
now with public wreck sweats tremendous
it's made for all sizes
get the best-selling all-day everyday
pant available in 40 different sizes so
it'll fit every type of guy even me i
got my chubby little legs and my flat
ass
i look tremendous in this i look like
richard gear and [__] the american
gigolo with this and my favorite part is
the pockets have zippers i told you that
nothing could fall out plus they make
shorts t-shirts jackets they even make
golf gear for you [__] golfies
so look sharp while you play
and [__] feel comfortable now let me
tell you something about public wreck
they rarely give out discounts but right
now
they have an exclusive offer just for
the joint family
go to publicrec.com right now
press and co joey and get 10 off what'd
you say joey go to publicrec.com right
now
press and co joey and get 10 off that's
public rec
rec.com
promo code joey for 10
off you're gonna sling dick and comfort
and style with public wreck tell them
uncle joey sent you you're gonna love
these [__] sweatpants guys they are
[__] tremendous
comfortable stylish
people the other day were asking me
where'd you get those you look like
[__] johnny bamboom i'm telling you
go to publicwrec.com right now pressing
joey these are the best 10
i've ever given you the joint is also
brought to you by one of my all-time
favorites you know i believe
cleanliness is next to godliness
the fall is coming pumpkin lattes back
to school halloween you don't want to be
walking around with stinky balls and
hair all over the [__] place you want
your nut sack to look like that [__]
character no
stop it trim your nut sacks you know i'm
58 years old i walk around with a skunk
black and white mix over my [__]
uncircumcised dick when i might want to
make it look like a [__] model i use
the new and improved lomo or 4.0 trimmer
i could give you a bunch of marketing
[__] but listen it's skin safe
technology bottom line it protects the
[__] nut sack
you want to your nut sack licked you got
to keep them [__] trimmed you
understand me you want your nut sack to
smell good that's why you got the crop
preserver the anti-shaving ball
deodorant and the crop reviver the ball
toner oh my god it smoothens out your
nut sack your nuts look magnifique
and it's all included in the performance
package and they also have
a [__] weed whacker to trim up your
nose hair and ear hairs with a 9 000 rpm
motor let me tell you something i'm
knocking coke rocks out i'm knocking
coke rocks out of that [__] from
1980 sorry about that i put the ad in
the camera who gives a [__] i almost
caught on fire i [__] love it that's
what it's all about but manscape i'm
gonna throw all that into the weekend
bag and it's called the performance
package crop preserver crop reviver the
poor 4.0
and the [__] weed whacker and the
beautiful thing about the performance
package it's now global you get it in
the usa canada uk europe australia south
africa and the singapore while you're
drinking a singapore sling after she
sucks your nutsack because they'll be
nice and [__] smooth i love manscape
you know they're one of my [__]
all-time favorites i trim my nuts i trim
the hairs out of my nose everything
with manscape.com so do me a favor i'm
going to get you 20 off and free
worldwide shipping
joy what are you talking about 20 off
and free worldwide shipping and you're
sitting there with that [__] mess
between your [__] legs you [__]
stink bomb go to manscape.com right now
slash joey i'm giving you 20 off and
free worldwide shipping there's no
reason why you should be sitting there
with that stink [__] bomb between
your legs never mind your [__]
[__] you filthy [__]
download right now manscape.com
preston joey get the performance package
you need this you sit out around all day
crying that you can't find a woman you
can't find a date because you're a
[__] stink bomb
that right now go to manscape.com
press joey and get that [__]
performance package and cut the [__] you
want people to suck your balls take care
of your balls and keep your balls fresh
with manscape.com
joey and the performance package i want
to thank manscape i want to thank the
hell out of public wreck and i want to
thank draftkings for putting money in
your pocket i'm trimming your nut sack
i'm putting sweatpants on you and i'm
putting money in your [__] pocket is
there anything else i can't [__] do
for you [__]
i love you have a great [__] day
enjoy the podcast and stay black you bad
[__]
[Music]
that's it take a hike it's time to
[__] go out there and let them know
you're not [__] around
[Music]
you